ça va peut-être paraître con ce que je
dire on va peut-être me prendre pour un
barge mais je dis même s'il y a des qui
m'écoutent moi je peux écrire des trucs
méfian alors tu sors un double album 23
titres qui s'appelle succès fou avec les
titres du début c'estàd Aline les
marionnettes avec les l'époque des
albums les mots bleus seorita tout est
bien dans dis à part la
pochette la pochette c'est risqué ouais
mais bon on on prend un risque B Picasso
pour pas c'est truc est fait aussi un
peu un peu vite fait ouais ouais c'est
pas ce qu' a mieux dans le
disque enfin tant que c'est que ça tu
t'en fous toi non je m'en fous pas je
suis pas d'accord mais bon c'est fait
ouais al tu es né j visisé sur Orge ton
père était installateur de chauffage
central et lestitte allit sur la côte en
stop
[Musique]
ouais
ma grande époque de la Côte d'Azur en St
64 ouais
c'est avec une chanson des comment des
qui s'appelait house of ringson ouais tu
le faisais ça à la terr je faisais
c'était pas connu je faisais dans les
boîtes de nuit d'abord et après je
faisais dans les dans les pizzas parce
que c'était pas connu j'aiécouté C ces
gens-l ouais c'est un traditionnel ça
j'écouté ces gensl sur Radio Caroline
ouais et c'est sorti en France un an
après et moi quand je chantais ça je
disais que c'était moi qui l'AVA composé
pour frer tu comprends on disait c'est
super moi je savais pas j'avais 15 ans
alors en 1964 tu vas à join Lespin tu
rencontres une fille qui s'appelle Aline
natthanovic qui était assistanteun
stomato et qui venit toujours t'écouter
justement chanter the house of the
rising sun et l'anné d'après pour elle
tuas composé Aline 65 tub énorme il y a
eu un procès quand même avec jaim mouard
parce que ça ressemblait à une chanson
qui avait sortie en
62 s'a la romance mais ça ressemblait
vraiment çaemblait pas mal tu sais je te
dire effectivement bon un procè je l'ai
perdu blocage du 45 saisi des recettes
et tout quand même ça pas rigoler du
tout là non ouais ouais mais si ve moi
j'avais 20 ans je dire j'étais moi sa je
faisais partie des des hommes qui se
baladent en roulotte je dire moi c'est
pas ça qu' allait me déranger ma vie
alors en 66 tu as fait les marionnette
67 monsieur le professeur mais en fait
tu avais la haine des tubes en fait
c'est pas du tout ce que tu voulais
faire toi tu voulais faire du rock tu
voulais être Danny baby et les les
houligans quoi ouais mais moi je voulais
plus faire du blues parce que si tu veux
ce qui ce qui m'a bercé dans les années
60 c'est quand même au cur King slim
tous ces gensl est-ce que c'est pas le
fait d'être devenu un tubeur français
par rapport au blues que tu voulais
chanter qui t'a donné une espèce de de
haine de toi et qui t'a amené à faire
toutes ces conneries parce que tu en as
fait après les conneries là à partir de
non je crois que j'ai jamais eu la haine
de moi non si c'est l'image que j'ai
donné c'est pas de ma faute c'est c'est
des gens la faute des gens pas compris
qui qui en fait ont fait une espèce de
presse un garde et nul c'est vrai que
bon un Gal jour le pognon qui arrivait
comme pas possible tu t'achètes un flat
avec Terrass dans le 16e les bolid enfin
tu es parti dans un drôle de trip un peu
peu popst C
ép plus la défense et l'alcool tu as
quand même bien déconné
comment la défense sarrêta au h oua donc
effectivement je fum un peu beaucoup ce
qui un peu par la suite m'empêch de
comment d'écrire et quand au bout d'un
an et demi 2 ans je
suis c'est grave là j'arrive pas trouvé
une idée j'ai balayé quand même oui
parce qu'en 69 tu t'es retrouvé ruiné
disparu quoi un moment tu as eu le trou
noir ah oui 68is 68 j'étais j'étais bien
j'étais loin de tout ça j'étais viment
dans Rê j'étais revenu dans mon rêve
quoi quand tu es revenu en 73 c'était
gymnastique je vais me faire pardonner
je fais de la peinture je suis sage et
là tu as fait tous ces albums avec
Jean-Michel j cé une époque formidable
ce que je voulais faire depuis longtemps
quoouis donc ce trou noir ça t'avait
servi finalement c'est ça t'avait servi
à te ah ouais mais tous les trous noirs
serv jusqu'aujourd'hui tous les trous
noirs la des trous noirs que que je
provoqueite parce que j'ai besoin de ça
moi je peux pas toujours je peux pas
toujours être dans le même truc il faut
il faut que je m'arrête de temps en
temps c'est pas possible sinon on pas là
tu as commencé à être aimé par la
critique à ce moment-là et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui des gens comme comme
Bayon par exemple disent il y a un côté
y pourri chez Christophe un peu
mensé bonne image quand même un peu
Gérard Moné un peu ouais il trouve ça
lui ah bah com bon il a du bon attention
je pense que commandant je pense qu'il
met quand même dans un à l'écart de tout
ça je pense
que mais le côté y est pourri c'est vrai
un peu quand même dans ces albums oua
ouais façon un peu sournois un peu
bizarre quoi ouais bon si tu veux le
problème dans ces
albums quand j'analyse aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'album que je suis en train
de faire tu vois c'est un peu le texte
quoi parce que de temps en temps bon je
fais un truc comme merci Joh d'êevenu au
mariage et là j'en suis fier parce que
c'est ouais bien sûr bah oui c'est parce
que c'est tout ce que j'aime
as SEOR moi je comment moi je suis un
écrivain
moi ça va peut-être paraître con ce que
je dire on va peut-être me prendre pour
bar je dis même s'il a qui m'écoutent
moi je peux écrire des trucs méfian et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater debe
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu